troops armed with orders to shoot those
indulging in violence are patrolling sri
lanka's capital colombo today armored
personnel carriers and soldiers with
guns have been deployed to prevent
rioting and violence a state of
emergency that was to have ended today
has been extended by another day in a
country facing its worst economic crisis
in 74 years the troop presence on the
ground has raised fears of a military
takeover of the country
those soldiers on the streets a response
to this a wave of violence after
pro-government supporters attacked
peaceful demonstrators in the capital
colombo
demonstrators are demanding president
kotabia rajapaksha stepped down for his
government's failure to prevent the
economic crisis
demonstrators on tuesday beat
pro-government supporters who attacked
them with sticks and rods 104 buildings
many belonging to lawmakers from the
ruling party were torched 60 vehicles
were burnt including buses which were
used to ship pro-government supporters
to where peaceful demonstrations were
being held
at least eight people have been reported
killed including a ruling party lawmaker
an opposition politician sought to
explain what was behind the violence on
tuesday he said it has been provoked by
the government and its supporters
all protests were peaceful protests
there was no violence there was no
rioting the protests were aimed at
specific demands of the people
when former prime minister mahinda
rajapaksa launched a planned attack on
these peaceful protests he should have
known there would be a reaction to that
the crisis forced mahinda rajapaksa to
resign as prime minister at the start of
the week his brother gutabia rajapaksha
continues however as president
following tuesday's violence he tweeted
a message of unity urging all sri
lankans to join hands as one to overcome
economic social and political challenges
he also warned against sri lankans
falling prey to attempts to push them
towards racial and religious disharmony
i'll be asking an analyst in colombo
about what the president was alluding to
in that last bit but first a look at why
so much of the public anger is being
directed at the rajapaksha family
political observers have called the
rajapaksha dynasty the most unashamedly
nepotistic regime in sri lanka's history
family members held crucial ministerial
births in addition to being in
parliament and other government
departments
the family has been a part of sri lankan
politics for nearly eight decades
starting with d.a rajapaksa he was a
member of parliament right after the
country declared independence in 1948.
four of his sons followed him into
politics mahinda rajapaksa was for years
sri lanka's most powerful person during
the 2000s serving as president for a
decade and prime minister twice gotabia
served as defence minister under mahinda
and is the current president their
brothers basil and charmal also held
cabinet positions finance and irrigation
before getting sacked in the current
crisis
and many in the next generation that is
sons daughters nephews in-laws and
cousins
all found purchase in government
we can't fit them all on our chart
but here's more on sri lanka under
mahinda and gotabia rajbaksha
the streets of colombo burn with anger
against the rajapaksas
symbols of their power have come under
attack
a dramatic turn of fortune
for a family that's dominated sri lanka
politics for nearly 20 years
starting in the mid-2000s two rajapaksa
brothers rose to power as a package deal
mahinda first as prime minister
then elected as president in 2005.
he appointed his brother gotabia defense
minister
in 2009 they brutally crushed the tamil
tiger insurgency ending a decades-long
civil war
and the family brand soared
mahinda won a second term in a landslide
he packed his cabinet with family
members who used their political clout
and billions borrowed from china
to plug budget shortfalls and fund
extravagant infrastructure projects
drowning the country in debt
in 2015 mahinda lost the presidency to a
non-family cabinet member
but four years later an islamist
terrorist attack renewed public fears
over security the rajapaksas vowed to
get tough and the people voted them back
into power
again a package deal
but this time gotabia as president and
mahinda as his prime minister
but in just 30 months their grip on
power has started to unravel
experts say their lacks finance policies
have caused the island's economy to
crater
shortages of fuel food and medicine have
prompted mass protests
calls for the rajapaksa family to go
at first went unanswered
but then one by one those in government
have started to resign
including mahinda
evacuated by army commandos after angry
crowds breached the gate to his
residence
gotabia still remains
in charge of the mess of his family's
making
and joining me now for more from colombo
is ambika sadkunanathan she's
chairperson of the ngo the nilan
thiruchal trust and former commissioner
in the human rights commission of sri
lanka amica there's a lot i'd like to
get your perspective on but first
how are you coping with this crisis
i would say that probably better than
most because i think it's important to
check one's privilege and i would say in
many ways uh in comparison to the daily
wage earners for instance the farmers uh
in comparison to many of those people i
would say i'm actually doing much better
because they are in dire straits
particular communities are severely
impacted and continue to be so
particularly those whose livelihoods
depend on
the fuel for instance which has been in
shortage the kerosene which has been in
shortage
i mean we saw a lot of them attacked by
pro-government supporters
on a tuesday yet earlier today in a
tweet president gutaba rajapaksa urged
sri lankans to court reject subversive
attempts to push you towards racial and
religious disharmony what was he talking
about
good question
it's quite interesting that the
president said that considering that he
came to power on an overtly sinhala
buddhist nationalist platform that was
anti-tamil
anti-muslim and at one point he boasted
about the fact that he was elected
by the sinhala majority and therefore
for him and we have seen even since then
since he came to power how the
government tried to use religion and
ethnicity to create disharmony to create
social instability we saw that multiple
crimes even inciting hatred inciting
violence etc therefore i feel that the
president's tweet is quite hypocritical
in this instance and there are also
demands for uh president gutaba
rajapaksa to step down yet a lot of the
anger appears to also be directed
against the rajapaksa family in general
why do you think that is
absolutely it is uh the initial demand
was for the president to step down and
that has continued that demand then
evolved to asking all the raj boxes to
step down and that is because this is
and this is something that if you go to
many of the protest sites and
particularly the main the large flagship
kind of site that is a golf face
uh
they call it a family business because
uh one of the brothers the president the
other one is the prime minister several
of the other brothers are ministers
they've got their family members
relatives their in-laws appointed to
many of the positions uh they're so it's
a family business that is run in a very
non-transparent undemocratic manner and
this is something that the people have
seen how there is corruption there is
nepotism there is patronage and
public resources are used for private
purposes and this is why the the demand
is not just for the president to step
down but for the entire family who are
seen to have exploited the country for
their personal benefit
yet one can't help but notice that a lot
of the people who are out on the streets
who are protesting are the very people
who voted this family into power
repeatedly i mean a number of times the
power has alternated between mahinda
raja paksha and gotabia rajapaksa and to
go back to a point you were making
earlier this was primarily on a
sinhalese majoritarian nationalistic
platform
do you think these people are having a
change of heart is there a different
expectation that sri lankans now have of
their politicians
yes and no
i would say uh largely the demands or
the the protest at least in the south
because we must remember in the north
these protests have been taking uh you
know they have existed for a long time
the families that disappeared for
instance have been protesting peacefully
non-stop for more than thousand nine
hundred days there are constantly
protests against the military takeover
occupation and acquisition of private
land in the north and the east so those
protests have been ongoing
but i think in the south it is primarily
started out only about economics and now
it has evolved to asking for the
abolition of the executive presidency
and also
demands related to corruption once again
a lot of the there is some difference
between demands from the urban protest
as opposed to the rural protests etc but
one demand is very clear for the family
to step down in terms of the other
issues i would say particularly among
the younger people there is an awareness
or wanting to learn more about the
historical issues the ethnic conflict
etc and there finally i feel sri lankans
many of them are beginning to understand
what it means to be a citizen and to
hold your elected representatives
accountable so their notion of
citizenship is definitely evolving and
changing and they're understanding their
role or what a democracy should be those
values i feel are perhaps slowly
becoming internalized
uh
we'll have we'd love to talk more but
unfortunately we're running out of time
ambiguous
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us today
thank you very much
and that's it for today as ever there's
more on our website we leave you now
with images from sri lanka where the
economic crisis has escalated troops
have shoot to kill orders a day after
protests turned violent a state of
emergency has also been extended we'll
see you back here tomorrow goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you